so this is probably the video that no
one including myself ever expected that
I would make I had botched CoolSculpting
almost got plastic surgery and I learned
a lot about loving my imperfect body
when I eventually decided at the last
minute tobacco yes this is going to
sound a lot like a certain TLC music
video but
this is actually real life hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
now a quick disclaimer here that I'm
going to be talking about my body and
weight and plastic surgery and the
pursuit of thinness so if this is
triggering for you please skip this
video I also want to quickly acknowledge
my obvious thin privilege through all of
this so if me discussing my personal
body image struggles in a straight sized
body is either triggering or in any way
offensive to you I fully understand
please feel free to not watch this video
let me hop in here super quick to talk
about my sponsor today skillshare so I
am a lifelong student at heart and as a
full-time content creator I feel like if
I'm not constantly learning new skills
and evolving I'm either going to get
left behind burnt out from boredom or
both so I love my skillshare membership
for picking up random new skills and
expanding my career in the past I
personally have always used my
skillshare account for classes in
photography editing and illustration but
skillshare also has hundreds of career
focused classes as well this year I have
some huge new projects in the works so
one of my goals is to really sink my
teeth into better understanding the
business side of what I do and exploring
different income streams I did a class
called productivity and time management
which was super helpful as I juggle a
million different balls and I also
finish the diversify your income and
earn passive income class they also have
classes in personal branding marketing
and silencing your inner critic I don't
think it matters what industry you're in
or want to be in everyone can use that
I've a really good feeling about 2023
and 2024 it just feels like something
huge is about to hit and I want to be as
prepared as possible for when it does so
if you want to also embark on something
new or expand your current career
skillshare is offering the first 1000 of
my followers to click a whole month free
of exploring skillshare's classes so
sign up for your free trial using the
link in the description to get started
today so I never want to minimize the
lived experiences of those who have
lived or living through societal
prejudices because of their body and
that's really really important here so I
just want to make sure that that's heard
before I go on I'm also going to use
this time to do a little meal prep
because I feel like I might need a
little distraction from the anxiety that
I'm feeling about telling the story
right now
this is one of these stories that I've
like sat on for a really long time
because I went through this period of
feeling so much Shame about the whole
series of events a chance series of
events but I do think that sharing my
story and how it kind of like changed my
whole perspective on my body may be
helpful discourse for a lot of my
followers so we're gonna unpack it
together probably gonna have
realizations in real time so a little
back story I've never had a super flat
stomach genetically like it's just not
how my muscles and fat distribution has
worked all through my life so even when
I was literally emaciated
um and like super sick with a severe
eating disorder my stomach still wasn't
fully flat like we see so many
influencers tout here on Tick Tock and
YouTube also if you don't know my Ed
backstory I had orthorexia not anorexia
so my goal actually was never to lose
weight that said once I had weight
restored and like physically recovered
so to speak I was still mentally
fighting really hard and obviously I had
gained a lot of weight really quickly as
part of my recovery which was very very
important but a lot of that weight ended
up kind of going to my stomach area
because I had lost a lot of muscle mass
as people do when they are severely
under fueling which kind of just
accentuated my not flat stomach and this
was in my early 20s at that point I had
like average female insecurities like
not pathological body dysmorphia but
regardless one day I was getting a
facial at like a Medi spa and I somehow
got sold a package of CoolSculpting well
now fear no mirror and eliminate those
problem areas with CoolSculpting I was
essentially told that I was a perfect
candidate because I wasn't fat but I had
you know trouble spots that died in
exercise wouldn't so easily fix if
you're not familiar with CoolSculpting
it's basically this technology that
gained popularity around a decade ago
like you couldn't walk past a nail salon
or a dermatologist without seeing an
advertisement basically it's considered
like a non-invasive of alternative to
light post suction that's usually how
it's sold so quick physiology lesson
here when we lose weight through diet
and or exercise our fat cells
essentially shrink but they never
actually go away and with liposuction
you actually like remove those fat cells
and with cool sculpting you freeze them
to the point of cell death and then your
immune system essentially eliminates
them in the weeks or months to follow
now like the short-term research that
I've read has found that it can
allegedly reduce fat in the area by like
15 to 25 percent but long term we don't
really know and also it's worth pointing
out that pretty much all of the research
is funded by the manufacturers of
CoolSculpting itself which is typical
with most drugs and medical equipment so
it doesn't necessarily mean it's bad
research but of course it's an FYI FYI
but anyways I was super young like early
20s I was eager to get to my like pre-ed
shape at least so I hit it over like a
ton of money and I said okay let's give
it a try so I'll show you what we did
basically let me just wash my hands
food safety just open myself up here we
did my belly like all this kind of stuff
and then like my flanks a couple you
know areas here and we probably did like
a few sessions each after a few weeks I
started to notice that my body kind of
looked like more lumpy it was like my
sides became uneven and got like a bulge
in my belly button area and it's
basically also where like a lot of my
pants would hit and it would rub and
like feel tender and just uncomfortable
it's hard for me to explain the
sensation but it still does irritate me
to this day it might just be like
phantom pain at this point I don't know
but still like I feel it feel it but
anyways I was concerned so I brought it
up at the spa and the solution of course
was to do more cool sculpting to try to
like fix the lumps and ironically this
just started to make them even worse
obviously I'd spend all this money I was
devastated I was horrified I didn't know
what the had gone wrong and anytime
I would go to another practitioner
another Spa they would just be like oh
yeah we can fix that with CoolSculpting
anyway over time as I like honed my
intuitive eating skills I learned to
respect my body I would say my
Devastation over the lumps started to
fade even though I knew and I know that
I live in a thin privileged body I did
still feel self-conscious about like
showing them off in bathing suits or in
clothes like I would never wear a bikini
I would never wear a tank top but I'd
definitely come a really long way and I
wasn't like staring at them in the
mirror every single time I got changed
it just kind of like blended into my
body and I was mainly reminded of them
when like certain pants would kind of
cut into one of them this one on my
belly so yeah I should probably like
show you what I am talking about I've
never done this before so
yeah kind of scary I like don't bring
attention to these parts of my body
generally and I've worked really hard to
like not notice them or not see them but
anyways here we are
I don't know if you can see with my mic
but basically my sides became very
uneven and lumpy after the CoolSculpting
I got this like hard bulge right here
and a bit of one right here
and the one that bothers me is this one
because that's often where like a lot of
my pants will ride and I can feel it you
can usually see it a little bit better
from the side it could have been worse
but
that's what I was left with and you know
even when I was pregnant it was like my
belly would accentuate the bumps and I
would like it would almost look like I
had a a hernia or a tumor or like a
permanent baby hand or foot jetting out
of me from from this one because it is
like a hard ball basically where was I
fast forward to like 2022
um I saw a article from Linda
Evangelista who came forward with her
like CoolSculpting Horror Story
basically Linda had had CoolSculpting
done instead of shrinking her stubborn
areas Linda says the sessions eventually
led to bulges that became hard and even
painful and it resulted in this like
complete severe disfigurement in the
treatment areas they describe this as
something called pah or paradoxyl
adipose hyperplasia and that was the
first time I'd actually heard that term
so essentially is it of cool sculpting
like freezing and eliminating the fat
cells like it's supposed to do
yes
it ends up enlarging and hardening them
and making them literally impossible to
get rid of so you end up with this hard
raised lump like a raised like brick in
your body in the shape of the
CoolSculpting applicator oh look see she
just she's just hanging out now we're
just gonna let her do that so Linda
actually apparently ended up suing
CoolSculpting for 50 million dollars in
Damages since it had prevented her from
working as like a supermodel I'll tell
you like I've done a lot of research the
incidents of pahs is like super debated
CoolSculpting says it's like one in four
thousand but one research paper that I
read said that it's one in 138.
and it's probably grossly under
diagnosed because it doesn't usually
show up until like months later so I
would think a lot of people just think
oh maybe I gained weight
now I don't know about Linda's treatment
but I was never told about the risk of
pah and no one stopped me after treating
me a few times and was like hey I think
this is maybe that rare side effect so
we'd better reach out to CoolSculpting
headquarters to like ask them what to do
next also FYI if you do decide to try
CoolSculpting make damn sure that you
are going to a reputable provider like
ideally a plastic surgeon hi everybody
who is very transparent about the risks
of pah but anyways it wasn't until I
spoke to a doctor myself and I read
about like Linda's experience that I was
confident that this is what happened to
me too so yeah that was like body
problem number one I got these tender
lumps in my belly and my sides that were
not the cute lady lumps that Fergie
likes to sing about my lovely little
lumps check it out I would like those
lumps
okay concern number two let's talk
motherhood so my first pregnancy with E
I had normal diastasis recti which is
the separation of the abdominal muscles
plus mild prolapse and you know I worked
really hard in physio to try to like
close the gap but then when my little o
came along he was a ninja in my belly he
kicked and turned and jumped and punched
like midwives and Physio and like all
the healthcare providers who put their
hands on my body were saying like I've
never seen such a violent fetus like it
was it was insane so not surprisingly
when he came out my abs were a
wreck so I ended up with severe
diastases recti and also prolapse and
this basically had a domino effect with
like a host of other issues in my body
so like I got a hernia because there was
like a huge gap between my abs and it
felt a lot of lower back pain when I'd
never had back pain before not even in
pregnancy spinal
it also was suspected that this is what
caused my ibfc and sibo and I'm still
not able to run jump or even like
properly walk downhill eating your pants
it's cool consider me Miles Davis and
this is after me going to pelvic floor
physio twice a week for a year and
training with a die Stacy's PT every
week on like specific additional
exercises like I have spent a small
fortune just like trying to fix my core
muscles so that I can live a normal life
and by the end of 2021 I was basically
told that it's better than it was but
you probably still need surgery to
actually like fix the problem I'm almost
three years in at this point and I will
say my core strength is so much better
now and I field my sibo through like
aggressive antibiotic and supplement
regimens functionally my body's never
been the same and I don't want to sound
ungrateful or angry like look at what
motherhood did to me I honestly am not
even mad about it like I'm an IVF mom I
fought so and hard for those boys I
wouldn't have cared if one of them
ripped me in half but by like two years
postpartum I was like okay I'm gonna go
see what my options are I went to a
surgeon we talked about the pah we
talked about my diet stacies she looked
at my abs and was like okay girl to
fully fix this I'm going to have to go
all the way up to your bra line full
Scar and full Scar from hip to hip
because I gotta sew all them ABS back
together and then like tuck it all in oh
and you'll need like 10 full months of
recovery well that honestly scared the
out of me because I had two kids
under four and they required lots of
lifting and lots of cuddling so then we
started talking about Alternatives that
would significantly help me but be a
little less invasive this is even like
hard for me to say out loud but the
recommendation was basically to remove
the pahs Via liposuction then to like
tighten the muscles underneath with some
kind of like frequency technology I
don't know and then to do like a mini
abdominoplasty on the lower abs rather
than like going all the way up so I went
through like a lot of back and forth on
whether or not this was something that I
wanted to do like I definitely knew that
it would improve my life from a
functionality and physical Comfort
perspective but I still had so much
holding me back like the first hurdle
was the guilt of doing something for me
as a mom of two kids who obviously still
really needed me and even if the
recovery wasn't going to be a full 10
months it was still gonna be many weeks
of just like not lifting and not helping
with the normal routines that I have
with the kids and honestly I'm just
really not good at asking for help with
all of my like unofficial jobs in the
family like the thought of me taking
time out of my responsibilities for like
someone that has like vanity project
Vibes even if it wasn't fully vanity
project it's just like really hard for
me to reconcile like
I I just
I couldn't us moms are just often not
good at doing things just for ourselves
and I'm just like particularly
guilt-played I can even take an hour on
the weekend to myself without feeling
like I'm failing my family and this is
not a testament to my husband he does a
lot he is a great dad and he picks up a
lot of slack and he would pick up the
slack but I just it's me it's me
the Second Challenge I had was just like
even the thought of slowing down for
Recovery I am not good at relaxing or
recovering I'm just like a really busy
body in a busy mind and when it comes to
die Stacy's recti repair it's like
things are gonna get way worse probably
before they get better and I was just
admittedly terrified of that process I
still am so I guess I was just trying to
like decide in my head if it's like bad
enough for the time sacrifice in my life
and third you know probably like the
biggest obstacle was just judgment like
from you guys of course but also from me
let me put this in the oven
every time I would have like an
appointment to discuss the procedure I
felt riddled with disgust with myself
that I Abby sharp someone who's based
her whole life around rejecting dye
culture even considered a surgery to
alter her body even though it was
largely for functional reasons like it
comes of course with aesthetic outcomes
that could theoretically reinforce these
unrealistic body standards that I want
so badly to be caught and I say
theoretically because I don't think that
this surgery would have made such a big
difference that anyone but me would
notice other than maybe that people
would notice a massive scar on my body
but still this is what was going on in
my head
and you know in the process of me trying
to like make a decision on the surgery I
also was digging deep into how I feel
about people getting plastic surgery in
general because for some reason my
disgust and judgment only apply to
myself like I have always said here I
believe in body autonomy and I know
loads of people even in my immediate
circle who have had cosmetic surgery I
don't care and I'm like good for them
like I don't think we should normalize
it or make it the standard and there's a
lot of things that I see people do or
I'm like
not my style but at the end of the day
I'm happy if they're happy and there's
lots of research showing that plastic
surgery can significantly improve
people's quality of life especially when
they're trying to restore a body back to
its previous form or function as I was
also hoping to do I wasn't hoping to
look like a drastically new or different
person and even if the reason is 100
vanity or aesthetic or even extreme who
am I or anyone else to judge you have to
let the person that you look at in the
mirror and if getting breast implants
gives you new zest for life and you can
access it and you want to amazing like
you do you do you boo boo do you boo-boo
the only major concern that I guess I
have with plastic surgery is the same
concern that I have with like
photoshopping or filters or other like
stealthy false Marketing Online like I'm
all about transparency like I'm telling
you the story right now and if an
influencer is like selling you their
body via a program but not disclosing
that they don't just do their 20-minute
workout they actually got like a twenty
thousand dollar BBL that's where I feel
like it's a slippery slope and it's kind
of like that scene in Legally Blonde
where Ali Larter would rather go to jail
than admit to her fans that she had
plastic surgery to get the body that she
was essentially selling to the masses
like a fraud my fancy that I bought it I
would lose everything you know I feel
like I've tried really really hard to
reject that narrative like if you eat
like me you can look like me because I
actually don't want to use my body to
sell anything that's why I'm always
repeating my body's unique my needs are
unique don't copy me do your own thing
for me I wasn't worried about like
selling lies but because of how far I'd
come from my Ed and my history like
loathing my body I was almost
self-interpreting this as an admission
of defeat in the world of diet culture I
was judging myself so hard with this
worry even though my personal opinion on
plastic surgery is very neutral I don't
think changing your body precludes you
from body kindness or body respect or
even body positivity but because I'm
just generally hard on myself I was
measuring Myself by a completely
different standard I had to be the
perfect poster child of diet culture
Dropout and these anxieties were
honestly becoming so crippling that I
eventually just decided that if I'm
having all of these thoughts and they're
bothering me it's probably not a good
time to even entertain the surgery and
as soon as I canceled it was like so
much weight had been lifted off my
shoulders and I was just like flooded
with gratitude where I was no longer
thinking about what was wrong with my
body and how I was having to go through
surgery to change it I wish I could like
bottle this realization and like give it
out to the masses because it happened
almost immediately but I went from
thinking so often about changing my body
because I was ruminating and having
anxiety over this surgery to full out
your body's amazing it can do so much it
looks great like not even like a oh it's
not so bad kind of attitude I was like
you're hot that body does so
much you come so far like that was
literally all I started here when I
looked in the mirror and let me tell you
before this realization I would never
show my stomach at all like never I tuck
into my high high waist jeans and put my
shirt down into it like completely
hidden but this winter when I spent like
nine weeks in Florida I was just
emboldened and exclusively wore crop
tops and like sports bras all the time
you could see my lumps and bumps and it
wasn't bothering me anymore like I just
adopted this I don't give a attitude I
can wear whatever the I want and I
really don't want people in the comments
to be congratulating me for like showing
us what a real woman's body looks like
because I actually want us all to
acknowledge that my body while a
departure from most Fitness influencers
that we see on Tick Tock is still a good
body a good body by Society standards
like I'm straight size I am healthy it
might be a little lumpy somewhere but I
fit into the standard clothes at any
store or my body is in the top few
percent so we actually don't just need
not quite perfect bodies to be
represented we need a much wider range
of shapes and sizes and colors and
abilities so please don't ever think I'm
not acknowledging the thin privilege
that I have in this world and that's not
to say that I won't down the road decide
to change my mind like functionally my
body's still pretty up me trying
to do a jumping jack not good and
aesthetically of course I have
insecurities too I'm not and like never
want to be the picture perfect poster
childhood body positivity because it is
just not realistic to look in the mirror
and be obsessed with everything you see
the lumps still bother me and honestly
my poor deflated breastfeeding boobs
really make me sad we all have our good
and bad body image days and let me tell
you staring at myself every day on Tick
Tock and on YouTube doesn't make it
easier it takes a lot of strength and
continual work to like what I see I
think if I ever were to revisit surgery
I'd actually be in a much better place
for it I'll be more secure in my
relationship with my body my intentions
my fears and my self-worth as a mom and
a woman and that's like a continual work
in progress I hope this story touched or
inspired some of you to try to learn how
to quiet the self-criticism in your
brain I know it's easier said than done
and I'm not perfect at it either and on
that note let me check on my egg muffins
oh they smell good they smell so good
yum but on that note please guys I would
love to hear your thoughts on plastic
surgery body positivity and if these two
things can coexist please give this
video the thumbs up leave me a positive
comment please try to be kind subscribe
to the channel and I will see you next
time for more real talk on Abby's
kitchen bye